[Music]
that brings us to new year's ma'am my
favorite time of the year
since i was a little kid i love new
year's and i talked about this last year
i just think it's hilarious that as a
culture we all just
give each other a mulligan no matter
what you can just
well i gained 811 pounds well
man
i tried crack a few times and now i'm
all like whatever the thing is and it's
like what new year's resolution time and
everyone's like sweet cool like control
delete let's do it
i actually started mainlining twinkies
well i'm off new year's great
so that's where we're at
so the other day i was hanging out with
my buddy
dr conway jp conway dude's he's
brilliant he's not as smart as his wife
dr conway she's
way smarter but he's pretty smart
and man we were talking about
resolutions and new year's what this
looks like and he gave me a framework
that i've never heard of before it's not
complicated or savant-ish or anything
but it's what i'm using this year so
i'll pass along my news resolution
framework and then i'll give you a
little bit of idea of what i'm doing
so here's the framework
identity who are you
body and mind
money
time
talent
that's it
identity body and mind
money time and talent
and so i start with identity i love how
james clear talks about this and um it's
it's proven in my life to be profound
when i'm trying to change behaviors i'm
trying to change habits i'm trying to
change the way i look at the world i
start with identity instead of starting
with goals
start with dude who am i who are you and
so here's a question i want you to
answer for 2022 coming up
who are you going to be in 2022 who are
you who are you going to be
here's what i wrote
i'm a funny joyful guy
i'm peaceful and patient
those are four things this past couple
years i've let slide
like man i used to just be a fun guy to
be around and now i'm all like drama and
serious and
let's listen to old metal okay man i
need to cheer up
the world sucks i want to cheer up we
need more joy and more smiling does that
mean i'm going to become a naive idiot
no
but that means if i've got a chance to
tell a joke i'm going to tell it that
means if
i can be a little more patient with
somebody who's working really hard on my
behalf i'm going to be more patient that
means i want people who are exp or in my
presence to leave a little more peaceful
than when they got there and that starts
with me being a person of joy
uh i have adventures i say yes
and
we've gotten back into that this year
but man that's all about the adventures
what's the craziest thing we could do
right now
do you want to fight jim yep want to go
on a crazy hunting trip yup i want to go
yep i meant and then i just got old put
on a tie
started going to work every day like
and i'm all about working hard yeah but
man i'll be about the adventure
i'm gonna i'm gonna be willing to lose a
couple hours of sleep for a great story
i'm gonna be willing to
like we talked about a couple shows ago
shoot a deer a mile into the woods and
figure out later how to get it out right
i i want to be about the adventure
i'm invested
i am an invested in world-class husband
and father
i want to be good at being a dad i want
to be good at being a husband and that's
gonna frame some of my activities
i'm a hospitable neighbor
uh man i was on the road a lot this year
i wanna be better about knowing my
neighbors i'm gonna be better about when
they think hey i need some help with i
can call that guy
just being a guy in my community that
people can think
i trust that guy let's give him a shout
he'll show up
and then people are less anxious after
being in my presence that goes back to
the top one but i want to be i've just
been around some folks i've been around
earn y'all and been around some folks
you're in their presence and your heart
rate drops
and i want to be that for folks i think
that's what the world needs right now is
a little less third rail
body of mind i'm gonna do one hard thing
a day that's pretty normal for me
whether it's like man chipping the ice
out of the cold tub yesterday oh man it
was cold taking cold showers my work i
worked out outside today it was freezing
like what i would do one hard thing a
day there is some days that i skipped
that i'm not gonna do that this year
um exercise workout movement every day
i'm gonna i gotta download an app 365
days i'm not gonna skip a day of moving
my body i'm not gonna have my goal for a
day be to do nothing
now that doesn't mean i'm gonna go
insane every workout doesn't mean i'm
not gonna have days where i
don't um
devote some time to some maintenance and
taking care of myself and
but
i'm going to every day i move my body
every day i'm gonna exercise workout i'm
going to do something towards continuing
to honor my body
um this year i think i'm going to hit
right at 50
books read for the year it's good it's
fine it's fine it's good but i wrote a
big book and that took a ton of time
writing books hard um and i'm excited
the book comes out this year i'm super
jazzed about it but this year i'm going
to move them up to 75 books i'm not
going to have a book to write i'm going
to be traveling a lot speaking and being
on the road with this new book and
coming out to y'all's town since i'm
excited for that but 75 books this year
it's for my mind
um
much man i got sucked into an office
vortex this year
man i've watched more tv in the last
seven months and i have probably lost
three years
man i'm done with that done with that
i'm gonna get back out i do love the
office it's a show that just it's like a
xanax for me but i'm i'm out um more
games i got some guitars that i'm
working on fixing i'm gonna hunt a
little bit more and we are making a
garden that's about the size of a small
planet at our on our place and so i'm
looking forward to that money um i've
got a
really audacious salary goal for this
year an obnoxious one i'm have to work
really hard and what i'm going to do is
i put i put that number down and then
i'm going to reverse engineer it here's
how much i got to make each month here
how much i got to make each week and
then we're going to reverse engine we're
going to fill those gaps in that way
um
i'm going to try to pay off my house
this year it's going to be hard hard
hard that's a stretch goal but figure it
out
i've got a giving amount that's going to
be obnoxious and obnoxious giving them
out
um and we're going to save and then i
fell off this year just with the
homeschooling and the back in school and
the ho
man it got to where doing budgets with
my wife was just our quiet time and
going over calendars and budgets and i
gotta bring my kids back into that they
need to see that struggle they need to
see how much things cost they need to
see their role as as a an important part
of our home
and i'm not gonna give them all the
details but they do need to know how the
world works and that starts with them us
me and my wife modeling budgeting and
then time dude i just waste a lot of
time i gotta slow
down i've got to be present
um
i just gotta stop wasting time so i'm
gonna do a time audit over the next
couple of days and really dial it in i
think i know i can get an hour or two
back each day and i'm looking forward to
that and then talents man what are the
things i'm good at that i
mean james playing music this year
i needed that that was good for me you
play every week huh you played for your
church
not quite every week but every couple
weeks see i just i don't i i need to
start playing um
and i want to be better at speaking and
obviously the book's coming out this
year and then i've doing some stuff with
my local community with the police
officers here in town and getting back
into some crisis stuff
crisis calls that gives me life and it's
something i'm good at so
there's some personal things in there
and some more specific data points in
there for this year but going back to
identity
body and mind
money time and talents that's the
framework i'm using this year from dr
conway
i recommend you use that framework give
yourself some sort of framework and then
here's the magic tell somebody
sit down and read this out loud grab a
couple of guys bring them over y'all
grab some beers and you'll say here's
what where's i'm committing to this year
here's what y'all are committing to if
you want to be gangster put 500 bucks in
a pot
i'm gonna run this marathon i'm gonna
save this much money i'm gonna earn this
much money i'm gonna exercise every day
and if i don't this pot goes to
the
charity of your choice
charity i hate the most in the world
whatever like put something in there
right i've seen guys like you can start
a workout program they take pictures of
each other and if they quit working out
then they're going to post the other
guy's picture whatever the thing is for
you
bring some women over your house y'all
all hang out and say say hey let's be
vulnerable here's what i'm gonna work on
as i'm gonna work on being a mom machine
i'm gonna work on being a wife this year
i'm gonna work on a girlfriend this year
whatever that looks like for you
um
and then by the end of the year we're
gonna reverse engineer that so i want
two finished guitars at the end of this
year that means i got to build that on
my calendar i want to actually take my
family on vacation i'm just going to
work it in i want this hunting trip i'm
going to work that in
and then we're going to have an
incredible intentional
year
the magic here is identity and
intentionality
we just think our problems are just
gonna go away
if we just ignore them they'll stop if
we just quit talking about it in our
mirrors it'll just fix itself
we want better sex we it'll just happen
it'll just happen i want to talk to my
kids better it'll just they're just in a
phase they'll grow out of it i want to
make more money and my boss will just
one day be like you know what 40 raised
for you
i just want
they don't just go away it's about
identity and about intentionality
and i'm with you i'm going first i want
you to join us
so if you're a real baller i want you to
write down your
new year's resolutions
mail them to me
and we will put the physical address
here in the show notes and over the
course of the year i'm going to reach
out to you and see how you're doing on
them
this is the ultimate bluff call 2022
bluff call the world needs you to step
up the world needs you to lean in here
let's get it done